[Music]
alright guys so world's going crazy and
you guys I know part enjoy your number
one fear is the world getting crazier by
having looting and rioting eyelets yeah
I feel like you guys have both that as a
fear and a dream yes how do you alright
well finish wise how much of it do you
want it to happen versus not happy I
think realistically I don't want it to
happen at all but romantically yeah I
want it to happen a lot I want to seem
like a badass you know you see watch
these movies you're like what's the
clothes I could get to that right going
on being crazy or like having zombies
happen or like looters and some are
having to protect yourself realistically
it's not gonna be a pretty sight dude
like just watching war footage and what
it really is like a seal war footage not
movies yeah it's pretty bad because in
the movies it's like adults and bad guys
and good guys in real life it's families
it's old people it's everybody on the
streets and that's where you know yeah
and that I don't really fantasize about
I think I'm thinking of a movie Rambo
kind of guy you know like I'm on the
roof but there's these bad guy looters
coming in you have like infinity bullets
infinity bullets you have no shirt on
it's like you know like like there's
like bad guy like war gangs that come
into villages and then they'll like kill
all the guys rape the girls steal all
the food like that kind of [ __ ] used to
happen right but like or it does still
happen in certain countries or whatever
and then I'm the [ __ ] good guy with a
machine gun on my Jeep and I'm just
[ __ ] mowing these bad guys down yeah
so it's justified killing because you
know they're bad guys right I don't know
so if this happens I'll bring the Jeep
you guys bring the guns and then I'll
pull it out the top yeah
oh yeah around town bad guys and then we
have to restore order in the chaos well
you finally say you talk about restoring
order because in Rome I like Rome had it
started happening right started
happening police are calling for order
now they're like hey we got to stop the
violence so they're coming out and what
are they looting food uh yet they're
breaking into clothes shops and stuff
shoplifting just taking us I don't know
if they're going into people's homes yet
but I think they're going into storage
right now just don't touch the old [ __ ]
don't touch trevi fountain or the
Colosseum you haven't seen it yet yeah
don't touch any of that old dope [ __ ] oh
you got to go visit it yeah the new [ __ ]
it sucks look over there yeah just go to
the Ferrari the Lamborghini go yeah go
to those luxury stores and [ __ ] they
have fashion you know all those clothes
just go take those shoes and stuff we
can never have that here because I feel
like people here or like they'll go tag
it up they'll do stupid stuff and it's
like they don't understand that you're
not supposed to do that okay this is art
that I'm adding to the piece you know
I'm sure I saw I've never been to like
the Lincoln Memorial where there's like
tagged up no and a security and it's
government you're gonna get sniped
there's so much security yeah that's
crazy
they're [ __ ] doing that right now
that's since it's Rome were in Italy
guess who the law enforcement think is
behind the rioting America nope China
nope
much more danger the Mafia amah yeah
they think the Mafia is coming out and
getting like basically serving civil
disobedience starting the riots and then
there's a rumor and this is like the I
guess the police force in Rome and their
intelligence they're thinking they're
doing this so that they the Mafia can
come back out and come out as a savior
at the end whoa they're trying to take
over the government they're trying to
take over the government they want
store order restoring the order that
they're actually destroying themselves
right now when it does turn into
conspiracy calling Wow unexpected
there's Martha that's if that's true I
forgot about the Mafia yeah because what
I think I've been well out there yeah
there are think so I mean they're really
they're saying the Mafia might be behind
the the unrest and now they're coming
back out now the idea is that there
aren't gonna offer loans to people as
well
oh no Sharkey people that need money in
a time of Christ that makes a lot of -
it is nuts to me cuz they can't pay that
this is not the kind of loan that we're
trying to find for Heroes they know this
is a go break your legs know break your
legs loan yeah I feel bad for Italy
there they have two criminal
organizations the Catholic Church in the
Mafia gonna do two big ass or criminal
organizations man this is it to news
today and there's smaller countries in
Africa right now that are starting to
lock down so people can't go to work but
then so what people are doing as a
result because they can't go to work is
that they're protesting or in writing in
big groups of numbers and I'm like
that's defeating the purpose of the
lockdown we're in like a lot of smaller
countries in Africa right now because
it's starting to hit them a lot harder
now so the government's are finally like
implementing a lockdown where people
can't go to work but I'm gonna get sick
people are protesting in big groups they
can't go to work they're like let us
work well the one guys today you say hum
yeah I don't want to wait in lines to
get food I'd rather just be working but
then so as a result they're protesting
in larger numbers so maybe they're not
in the work educating their public well
enough like I have a so I have a
co-worker that was mentioning this that
was mentioning this to me like about two
months ago um no no about like a month
ago when we were starting to go into
quarantine and she was like yo guys like
I've been on block Twitter and like
she's going wild on that Twitter blog
Twitter I mean it's just a it's it's
Twitter for my there is a big part a big
party like culture yeah yeah so like
there's like some wild theories and one
of the theories is like cuz at that time
Africa wasn't hit Ernie
like that right and so they're like yo
man why are black people like not
getting infected and then black people
like what are you trying to say and then
like there's theories where is just like
oh you know um because black people have
like a high melanin count yeah like
they're not affected that's very
interesting theory about the numbers as
of this week though in in all the states
and cities that have like let's say 18
percent of black people the death rate
is like 50 60 percent black people out
of the people in the hospital or in
Seoul 50 percent yeah because of you
lesion is actually getting hit and
they're actually I talked about that
today because of diabetes and stuff like
that which is higher in black oh man
that's sucks dude yeah cuz the the whole
Rona's is that if you have a
pre-existing condition yes like yeah
it's like asthma if your smoker what is
me damn lung condition conditions are
the big two yeah you got to watch out
that's the one thing that I was scared
of I want to get tested dude I think I
had it man I don't want to get tested to
just wait till after oh yeah that's true
cuz what if I get it at the hospital
getting tested that's what's happening
to a lot of people do that I think that
cause they're testing people so they
literally high like sad Dodger Stadium
right they had a long-ass line right and
they'll have someone literally stick
that like the long q-tip into the back
of people's throats uh and it makes you
skin a swab people say they're crying
cuz it hurt um how far it went in right
but then I just pee in a cup or
something I don't know you just take
your blood or something right oh the
respiratory so I need to be mucus yeah
they need the mucus right so then
they'll do that they'll take that and
put that in there but you see everyone I
will do it they were like half because
it itches right yeah and then you see
that happening right then the doctor
puts that in and then they use another
one right so they go but then I'm like
the nitrogen the Glover well it's the
same glove that you play I'm I'm like I
wouldn't want to go there because you
could just be infecting there they're
not switching loves every time they're
not doing a lot of their costly me like
a preacher at communion [ __ ] giving
little yeah so it's like even then like
you can go get tested but you're fine
and then you actually get it yeah a lot
of hospitals are strong has changed
their rules because before the nurse had
to be the one I did it for you because
you need to do correctly but the
problems that every time they did that
all of their stuff would get ruined they
would need new supplies so now they're
starting to let people do it themselves
they're like here's the q-tips
okay now put in your nose so that way
they can save their own supplies more
giving them instruction from a distance
now so they go now through the I think
the mouth right hi this is the mouth or
the nose both a lot of putting goals
like the bubble can't cough yeah but
they can fire again [ __ ] yeah but it's
uh it goes so it's like the throw and
the music apart behind it that they go
in there oh that's why it hurts because
it goes all the way in the back but uh
like they're saying if you don't feel
symptoms just stay at home or if you do
feel sick don't go into like it gets
really bad the mystery is getting to me
whether you have it or not that's a hard
part cuz you wanna know if you have it
what I want to know if I already had it
so like when was the last vegas JK
tripping when I wasn't in 2019 the last
one
yeah last year so my so I didn't get
sick when everyone got sick last year in
December but I got really sick on the
last JK trip the one where I was only
out for that one night to play craps and
actually I'd to go to Urgent Care and I
hadn't had the one where you hadn't
liked the IV bag yeah IV bag I went to
the urgent care that the Panera recipe
that's just sick the Rona's was way
after that though yeah so I thought so
for me I'm like I don't know maybe I
cost the really first I never got that
sick ever in my life were like cuz I was
literally in bed and my father calls
breathing out of a straw and I was
telling gia on my [ __ ] I need to see a
doctor now it's a really [ __ ] I'm gonna
die and should I shut out on my mic off
and I complain about [ __ ] so that's true
I I even called the I was looking online
where they cuz in Vegas anything can
happen right you can get doctors to come
to your room so I found this ad where
this guy will come and visit me for 500
bucks on my [ __ ] and I feel like I'm
gonna die so I call them and then he was
like oh it's gonna be a thousand and I'm
like what the [ __ ]
I thought you it's just 500 little it's
3:00 a.m. my [ __ ] I'm to Chinese with
[ __ ]
I rather die than pay thousand [ __ ] that
[ __ ] yes I rolled over and then I went
to Urgent Care and then so they said I
had pneumonia got a chest x-ray so that
was the worst that I ever had it so I'm
hoping that if I went through that maybe
I am immune to it now cuz I have
antibodies if I did catch it but I don't
know we're so close to us at the time we
would we would have had it too but I
think that well that goes again if
everyone it's like the first wave why
didn't everyone get sick or what were
they like a lot of people died in back
then also like the first way when
they're saying when he got hit
California oh because it wasn't a spike
it was a curve a lot of people are also
dying because of the lack of attention
and help and ventilators and equipment
so then that's what they're doing right
now is flattening the curve right so
what one of the theories is we did this
the other day but California is not
getting hit as much as it's supposed to
because we slowly got it around last
fall and then it was kind of dispersed
throughout the population so a lot of us
might have the antibodies for it in the
fall time I thought it was more well
known in December and that's what
doctors are saying that around fall in
December yeah around like like early
winter because 8,000 Chinese coming to
LA daily which is like 3-4 million in
the west coast alone a year and a lot
from Wuhan - so that's what that's what
one of the theories is is that we're not
getting hit when we should there's only
like 300 something deaths and we're
supposed to be seeing our peak but we're
not and people were just waiting for it
I want to get tested yeah I do too I
just want to see because I have some
crazy cost and then if I did I could be
like ha I got it from a white guy I
wanted to get that because I feel like
you can start helping out once you if
you find out your yeah can't you get it
again no no the big thing is that
because I know people are donating
plasma blood plasma if you already had
it yeah I've helped people who are
currently have it so I'm like I want to
help out if all you're gonna get blood
if I had it it can't mean anyway but if
I didn't have it
I'll give money but no blood I get too
tired
[Music]